this is it's a horrible toy for kids  this has got the worst of everything all  rolled into one you're this slime thing  I don't have a buddy here has kids but  they're all about slime now making slime  and playing with slime it's [ __ ]  awful yeah and then you got poop  involved to it and then you got these  girls in this commercial wearing wigs  like they're working at a pump Nevada  brothel it's all very strange here's the  commercial will you make poopsie plan  surprise  key chain keeps poop fresh last selling  point of the toy you know what if you  don't want stale poop Evan  somebody had to write that line and they  were like man why did I bother going to  [ __ ] grad school  [Music]  you  [Music]